hi there steve here again um remember if
you enjoy these um
videos please subscribe to my channel
today i'm going to talk about a few
things first of all
i had a a skype chat
with aj hoag of effortless english whom
many of you know and i think he's a
great
um enthusiastic teacher
with some wonderful
teaching resources and a great attitude
towards language learning helping people
learn english we had our
skype interview but the quality of the
sound the connection was so poor i'm not
going to put it up
i'll tell you what we talked about we
talked about the problem of people who
plateau in a language and feel they
can't get to the next level so i'm going
to kind of talk a little bit today about
the kinds of things that we discussed
in our video
however
after our video
aj and i then continued our discussion
in a podcast which you can find under
effortless english podcast
and the sound quality was much better
and
it made me realize that you know i would
like to do podcasts because i would like
to talk to people
i would like to talk to people about
language learning not just language
learners not like not just teachers like
aj
but people in different walks of life
with different perspectives why are they
interested in languages how do they go
about learning languages things that
relate to my interest in languages and
we can do them in english and french and
chinese any language that i'm
comfortable conducting the discussion in
so if you are interested or know of
anyone who is interested please let me
know but these will be podcasts they
will not be video because the quality of
the
screen and the the audio is simply not
good enough
and so that's one thing that i will be
starting and i will provide more
information on that later
another small housekeeping item before i
get into the subject of plateauing uh
our many stories project is proceeding
we have
lots of volunteers helping us translate
these many stories into different
languages
uh we need more we need more in a
variety of languages i'd like to see
there
you can follow it at the
forum at link
but in particular we don't have people
for
volunteers for
or enough volunteers or any volunteers
for chinese japanese and korean so today
after this video i'm going to do some
videos in those languages to try to
encourage speakers of those languages to
participate in our project which i'm
very excited about now
the plateau
aj
raised this as something that comes up
all the time people feel that once they
have achieved a certain level and say
english because he basically just
teaches english they have trouble
getting to the next level and i've
discussed this before you know
breakthrough getting to the next level
and we talked about the things that were
important aj pointed out that there is
also a psychological
dimension to this and i agree
basically what i feel is this
there are different kinds of people who
are at a plateau
you can have someone who is at a very
high plateau you can have someone who's
at a low plateau
you can have people who feel that their
say level of english or whatever
language is simply good enough so
they're not bothered by the fact that
their language has reached a level and
it's not going to get much better they
pick up the odd word but by and large
they will continue making the same
grammatical mistakes they will continue
with the same pronunciation and it
doesn't bother them and they're happy
and they go about their lives very often
immigrants fall into this
category
however there are other people who are
unhappy about their level they would
like to speak better they would like to
have you know better pronunciation or
they often find themselves in situations
where they don't understand or they're
unable to express themselves and so
forth so what can these people do well
i think there are a number of things
first of all
i think a lot of people are unduly hard
on themselves it is unrealistic to
expect that you are going to
speak like a native speak with native
pronunciation
never make grammatical mistakes
never find yourself in a situation where
you don't understand that i think is
going to be there so so i you know
i always feel that wherever i am in
language i'm happy that i'm able to do
whatever i'm able to do i never get
unhappy
with what i'm able to do in a language
even those that i
i'm not very good at like romanian or
something
um i'm happy i enjoy what i've been able
to do in the language
so i try to be positive however if i
want to improve
then
i go back to the three keys as always
the attitude of the learner the time you
spend and the ability the ability to
notice your awareness of what's
happening in the language so
to me it's very simple if you want to
improve in the language you have to
begin by wanting to improve you have to
deliberately want to improve
attitude wise you actually have to want
to leave the comfort of your own
cultural environment
as an individual you can't take your
whole
cultural group with you you actually
have to leave that warm fuzzy feeling of
your
might be english-speaking environment or
it might be chinese-speaking environment
or french-speaking environment and you
have to throw yourself in to this other
environment you have to want to do that
you have to want to you want to enjoy
that so that's the psychological element
you have to put in the time if you are a
chinese immigrant living in vancouver
and every evening you watch chinese
television watch chinese videos
that's not going to do it you have to
put in the time you have to read novels
you have to push yourself
watch you know english television so
those kind of things and
you have to improve your ability to
notice notice where your own
pronunciation is you know could be
better could be clearer okay
you don't have to be like a native but
if there are parts of your pronunciation
that are not unclear you have to be
aware of it so you have to listen to
yourself and compare yourself to a
native insofar as pronunciation is
concerned focusing on intonation as much
as anything else
i often refer to my father who said you
know
bank of nova scotia province in canada
it was always nova scotia and work was
vork he came from czechoslovakia it
never bothered him but if he had wanted
to improve he would have had to notice
that actually it's not pronounced scotia
it's pronounced scotia you have to
notice these things and insofar as
grammar is concerned i find it useful
from time to time to review the grammar
whether it be you know i think of
romanian i downloaded the grammar of
romania i have a greek grammar that i
downloaded i go through it i don't try
to memorize but all of these things help
me become aware of the language
better when i listen and read and of
course the biggest thing is in order to
improve get past the plateau you just
have to put in the time lots of
deliberate time reading reading things
that are a little bit challenging on a
wide variety of subjects listening
watching movies
um and then speaking of course and you
have to speak without being hung up but
you have to speak and try to put into
practice try to you know activate the
vocabulary that you have acquired so if
you have this deliberate
policy of of wanting to improve of
pursuing that uh you know effort that
improvement you will improve
however if you're happy with where you
are if you can communicate you work
you uh you know you read you do things
and you have an accent and you make some
mistakes
you're fine i know so many people that i
communicate with in english
um you know and and i've often said this
you know the german person who says i am
living in vancouver since many years
which of course is not correct or the
swedish person says it is many people in
china instead of there are and all of
these things that we bring from our own
language and i'm sure that i do the same
in some of the languages that i speak
but i'm happy so
you know it's all a matter of what you
want to do if you feel you're in on a
plateau and you want to do better you're
going to have to put that effort into it
and you're going to have to be prepared
to leave the comfort of your
native language cultural environment and
you're gonna focus on
as much exposure to the language as
possible both in the form of input and
output with the occasional effort of
looking at some grammar aspects and
seeing if that helps you notice things
uh when you are
either uh you know reading and listening
or using the language so there you have
it with regard to the plateau
any ideas you have about people i could
speak to for my new podcast series we're
going to talk about you know it's a
small world we live in the global
village language
how do people use language why are they
interested in language different
perspectives on the advantages of
learning languages whatever it might be
that's what i want to talk to people
about please let me know
and
that's it
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you